هل لم تشاهد صور جميع
الأطفال وهم ليسوا
مدنيين فلسطينيين أبرياء في جميع
أنحاء العالم عندما تنظر إلى الناس الذين
يتضورون جوعا حتى الموت، ونصف مليون
شخص يتضورون جوعا حتى الموت هم الأشخاص الذين
يجب أن يخرجوا إلى هناك ويضعوا حدا لهم؟  الحكومة
القائمة لا تخرج إلى هناك
وتهاجم إسرائيل بشكل يومي،
كبار السن يدمرون
البنية التحتية في غزة أكثر مما فعلوا في
دريسدن، لذا فإن هذا يشبه
تدمير المزيد من غزة، ما حدث،
هل هناك المزيد مما يجب
تدميره و  سيكون هناك المزيد من الأشياء التي
سيتم تدميرها، أريد
الاحتفاظ بها، أريد التأكد من أننا
لن نعطي فلسًا واحدًا للأونرا
وأن يتم إلغاؤها تمامًا،
لماذا تم إنشاؤها في عام
1948 لخدمة اللاجئين
فلسطين هذا ما خلقوه من
أجل الأمم المتحدة خلقته لأنهم
نزحوا من المكان الذي يعيشون فيه والأمم
المتحدة كانت حمقاء لأنها خلقت أونرا،
أنت بلا قلب، هل تدرك
مدى قسوة قلبك، هؤلاء الأطفال
يُذبحون والآن تريد أن
تأخذهم  تخلص من آخر جزء من الطعام والماء
والإمدادات وأي دواء، هل تريد أن
تأخذ آخر جزء لديهم وتأكد من أن
أموال الضرائب الخاصة بك لن تذهب إلى UNR سأفعل
كل ما بوسعي للتأكد من أنهم
لن يفعلوا ذلك